we have a voicemail number and that
number
is a 2192 david p
now i am i'm glad to be corrected on
this program i love it
um on the bonus show the other day pat
and i discussed
the idea of vaccination stickers a
sticker that says you've been vaccinated
and we talked about the possible
positive impact of that including that
it would create
uh sort of like a public movement to
encourage others to be vaccinated but i
heard from a bunch of people
with a very different view and clearly
this is the privilege i have of living
in
a blue area folks who live in red areas
have written in saying those stickers
could get you attacked
and the egg man who lives in a rural red
upstate new york wrote in uh or rather
called in
and said exactly that take a listen to
what he had to say
hi dave and pat i'd like to respectfully
disagree with your opinion
on wearing the i got vaccinated stickers
yeah i live in an area that is so
red that if i went around with an i got
vaccinated
right i might get assaulted i'm not even
kidding with you
i actually gave blood this morning and
the nurse who took my blood
told me i would never get that vaccine
it's horrible it's not tested
she literally mentioned right wing
talking points but i hear trump say all
the time conspiracy stuff
i'd be afraid to wear i got vaccinated
sticker
the same way as i'm afraid to put i
voted for joe biden sticker on my car
in the area that i live thank you shalom
yes all right shalom is well to it to
eggman peace and love
he he's right and uh i i think maybe
pat and i were a little bit um uh uh
anxious on the trigger of saying this
would be a great idea because there are
people in
in many parts of the country who uh
may not so easily be able to just walk
around with their i'm vaccinated sticker
it could actually cause them problems so
let's continue to think about it and
think about the right way
to sort of publicly encourage folks to
get vaccinated but i think the egg man
brings up a very good point
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the swedish king
carl the 16th gustav says
that the coronavirus approach in sweden
has not gone
so well we will talk about the possible
return of the iran nuclear deal
we will talk about an important supreme
court decision that may be coming soon
get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com